pictures into us from Sandra and this is
the Queen leaving some Mary Magdalene
Church after the traditional Church
surface this morning around half an hour
or so ago she left the service along
with other members of the royal family
now usually the Queen actually goes to
talk to the well-wishes some of whom
have been there since five o'clock this
morning hoping to get a glimpse of the
royal family but we understand the Queen
was whisked off probably rather chilly
for her didn't want to hang around too
long this morning you can see there I
Kate just behind him with a husband
Prince William of course a little bump
showing underneath Kate's coat I think
four months or so pregnant by now and
this is the rest of the war family
greeting those crowd spouses have lined
the route into the church today as I
mentioned a moment ago some as early as
five o'clock this morning it's become
quite a traditional thing though and the
crowds growing every year because it's
one of the few opportunities throughout
the year the people guaranteed to get up
close and personal with all the members
of the royal family one of the few
occasions that they are all gathered and
they get to have a chat with them we can
see in a moment lots of people out with
their cameras trying to get those
selfies and here they are Prince William
and Kate there and Prince Harry
just behind meeting having a chat with
those lucky few at the front of the line
Prince Edward and his wife Sophie there
as well and their daughter so having
each other's they be the church Princess
Royal just behind them as well well
family event to the royal family
gathering for Christmas Day apparently
they are now talking down to a Norfolk
Turkey of course things though they are
in Norfolk with all the trimmings a lot
more family apparently and have a
tradition of opening their Christmas
presents actually on Christmas Eve now
you'd have noticed one person who was
absent the youngest member of the royal
family gorgeous Prince George Kate and
William deciding to keep him warm at
home with the nanny
also Camilla was absent today apparently
she has put to have back out so she did
journey to church but lots of people are
getting an opportunity to get their
photos with some of members or cleat or
family